706 you have exactly eight hours and 54  minutes to ponder the error of your ways  any questions yeah it's Barry Manilow  know that you raid his wardrobe a brain  a beauty a jock a rebel and a recluse  can't believe this is really happening  to me before this day is over they'll  break the rules chick cannot hold II  think that would mean there are their  souls I'm a nymphomaniac your parents  awareness take some chances being bad  feels pretty good and touch each other  in a way they never dreamed possible  why'd you do that Sammy wooden The  Breakfast Club  they only met once I wanna be alone  anymore you don't have to but it changed  their lives forever and I consider you  guys my friends I'm not wrong am I  Universal Pictures presents Emilio  Estevez Falls leeson Anthony Michael  Hall Judd Nelson Molly Ringwald and Ally  Sheedy in a John Hughes film Raymond  semester cuz you're letting me The  Breakfast Club